aber ich finde ich es gut dass es so
viele neue sachen gibt im neuen es
eigentlich auch gar nicht mal vor allem
auch so sachen die einfach mal einfach
sind also ich meine beim brauner wir
jetzt schon gebraucht bis ich das
wirklich eine klage kommen will
es muss ja auch mit fackeln da können
fehler neues thema jener neues thema a
ha ha ha jung
sobald es jetzt ja so mache ich das auch
kein das thema von dsds dann noch mal
okay dann lese ich jetzt wie ein roboter
diesen kommentar vor den avancen wir den
überwachungswahn dass sich unsere
privatsphäre immer mehr eingeschränkt
wird sie geben vor so welche
überwachungssysteme errichten um uns vor
terror zu schützen
was bedeutet dir deine privatsphäre
fragezeichen europe gehen
okay er hat ja auch die frage mit
bekommt ja da kann man direkt auf
facebook beziehen
da wird der mittlerweile auch alles
überwacht in chats und alles mögliche es
geht auch noch mehr auf private bed von
staatlicher seite aus also erlaubt haben
das privatunternehmen spionage drohen
benutzen
die privaten unternehmen dürfen spion
benutzen und dann ziemlich viele leute
doch die barbie ist schon ziemlich das
wobei das noch aufs internet beziehen
würde ich meine einem jeden muss klar
sein egal was man im internet tut alles
immer davon muss man ausgehen
ich würde diese kommentar frage noch
mehr auf die staatliche seite beziehen
also nicht auf das privatunternehmen wie
facebook oder sowas machen
er war klima sondern meine welt was die
stadt also zum beispiel
überwachungskameras an allen
öffentlichen plätzen also zum beispiel
werde ich london geht
ich weiß nicht wie viele tore das essen
ist an jeder haben wir gott ländlichen
räume sind schon noch
50 ja ist es an jedem öffentlichen platz
allerdings keine in der innenstadt gibt
es kaum einen platz wenn ich also gibt
es gar keinen platz und kaum eine straße
die nicht kameraüberwacht ist einfach
für die kriminalitätsrate sehr sehr hoch
ist wer und was haltet ihr davon lieber
mehr kameras oder würde ich sagen
um mehr sicherheit jetzt irgendwie zu
haben bestimmt nicht mehr spionage da
bin ich dagegen immer mehr kameras
aufstellen
weniger spionage mehr kameras ich meine
dass das rechtlich habe das spionage zu
das internet bezogen dass man weniger
gut sagt mal es war die rede davon dass
mein jets kontrolliert sage ich mal
guckt okay was schreiben die da
schreiben die da wenn er in gehlberg das
heißt nach sex war das noch und noch ein
paar andere sachen wenn die alle
zusammen der reihenfolge von vorkommen
dann wird das sofort dem start gemeldet
alles möglich ist so was finde ich
sollte man nicht machen sondern denn
schon eher mehr kameras also soweit ich
das jetzt ja es behandelt die auch
verschiedene sachen also ist es ja mit
kann er zum beispiel solche gewalttaten
zu verhindern wie jetzt das da in der
u-bahn die leute zusammengeschlagen
werden
und das ist jetzt ging pädophile
verhindern kannst du sowas team hat ist
verhindert kannst du sowas hat es nur
nach hinten also jetzt mal ganz also
brüchen überwachungskamera werde das
fahrrad die wir auf jeden fall
eingeschränkt und immer sagen ja aber du
kannst es trotzdem ich verhindern dass
das fahrrad in dem moment geglaubt wird
aber die liebe lassen sich ja dann eher
davon abschrecken als bestimmten
statistische starker rückgang der
fahrraddiebstähle wenn der kameras sind
nicht dass die sich da abschrecken
lassen das ist jetzt genauso wie bei
zigaretten da steht auf jeder packung
drauf brauchen natürlich trotzdem 8000
ja alle research center
ja aber philipp ist noch was anderes ob
er denn dabei erwischen und dem
gefängnis landet oder ob er urlaub der
raucher raucht weil er süchtig danach
ist und nur für sich selbst irgendwelche
gesundheit haben könnte eine frage ganz
schnell zwischendurch die und
bilderrahmen
jetzt bin ich wieder drin meint website
rumgesprochen ich muss das einmal kurzes
ausnahme an ok leder kev wird also diese
bilder habe ich dachte in der mitte
leder und außen rum die sticks es geht
bei mir dich doch klar
außenrum gekoppelt leder und draußen rum
leder rhein ein weg herum und ein lehrer
in der mitte es habe ich aber ach so ich
habe kein feld bei meinem text habe ich
kein feld dafür fehlt einfach beim
techniker stehen
ich weiß nicht was ich da ich habe da
ein janina kraft 1.4 als basis für
genommen und das dann einfach ein paar
sachen von mir ein gefühl ich irgendwas
habe ich gefehlt hier saß dort aber
nicht zum download anbieten von der nina
kraft schon von minecraft unbedingt
geboten habe weil vom eingebracht
brauche ich eigentlich immer von
minecraft bräuchten eine erlaubnis von
handball direktor dafür weil ich sehr
kommerziell sozusagen anbiete weil meine
videos auch monetarisiert sind und ich
hab dir nämlich damals gefragt weil ich
hatte ja auch von pec zusammengestellt
am lg modell das zum download anbieten
aber nur wenn man wirklich ein schreibt
wirklich von mir weil die ball oder
meinst du dir die giannina kräftige mann
hat die beiden gut obwohl es sich
angeschrieben youtube antwortet sie
nicht das ist aber schon locker ein
halbes jahr her da war sie halt auch
noch falls sie wahrscheinlich noch
weniger ps gehabt als jetzt aber daheim
0 antwort also wenn und ich habe sonst
ich habe auf ihre gesucht eine
e-mailadresse nichts gefunden und wenn
sie mir keine erlaubnis dafür gibt oder
muss ein anderes texture pack suchen
kannst janina frank hat ja auch die
rechte verwendung ganz marl hüls
texturen hier von mir deswegen verändert
die einfach ein bisschen
ja kann es auch einfach so zum download
anbieten und dann wenn sie dann auf
drauf aufmerksam wird
aber wenn wenig hier keine möglichkeit
habe dann darf es auch nicht machen wenn
du keine ja ich weiß oder damals selber
und auch selber mal bringt nämlich voll
ab weil hier sehen wir bei solch machen
wollte
ach so wir haben ein neues thema da
haben sich schon als formuliert gerade
was öffentlich überwachung stimmt die
richtung ist richtig geil geworden bei
mir hat sogar wieder ein bisschen meinem
haus weiter damit die ganzen hater ruhig
sind irgendwie ist das ganz komisch die
item frame ski in sogar also man sieht
die textur von den an der wand sieht man
nur kräfte das schild bei mir
funktioniert ja auch ich sehe ihn nur
nicht im inventar aber ist trotzdem
immer wieder ein problem c
minecraft nach zuerst mein ziel der lag
voll hat irgendwas zu essen ein bisschen
ich voll werde ich lege mich hier
natürlich die welt ich bin eigentlich
auch fertig ich brauche nur noch gelbe
blumen und ein bisschen wolle
gelbe blumen und soll da brauche ich
selber ich fahr mal was selber von den
schafen kurz dass er noch ein bisschen
zeit also dass jetzt noch nach 22
minuten
die haben so viel scheiße ich bin jetzt
fertig eigentlich muss man acht wollen
bin ich fertig theoretisch auch bei dann
oder oder du fenster noch ein bisschen
erde für mich mit dann meist macht jetzt
wartet man nicht eine ungerade zahl hat
folgen
hallo ganze wolle aber bitte drin lassen
und fertig ein gericht relativ schon mal
fertig eingerichtet jetzt kann ich mich
an mein haus hier oben dran wagen so
schlafzimmer essenstechnisch wie sie das
aussehen uhr ein rohes rindfleisch oder
das ist marca dass ich dann in einklang
mit 23 knochen von dir mit weil dann
fahre ich einfach mega kartoffeln ist
okay ich hab dich selber was in einem
land aber ich kann doch kartoffeln für
euch waren dabei der gibt mir das stimmt
natürlich fahrkarten genauso wie
gebratenes fleisch wieder jaba kann
macht kann man eigentlich diese posten
protest kann man die auch backen und
dann sind sie normal
ich glaube nicht auch schon das war ich
weiß es aber nicht ich finde ich gut
dass er so viele neue sachen gibt einen
neuen arzt eigentlich auch gar nicht vor
allem auch so sachen die einfach mal
einfach sind also ich meine beim brauen
habe ich jetzt schon eine zeitlang
gebraucht bis ich das wirklich klar
gekommen bin
mittlerweile ist echt zu sachen die ich
mir schon mal gewünscht so irgendwie
neue sachen zum fahren und so was alles
das sind so sachen es ist glücklicher
option das ist halt in kronenburg lassen
auch schön und so ist auch toll jetzt
reicht sie aber so alters bei mir ich
bin nie zufrieden baue ich immer noch
mal halabdscha das ohnedies um ich
könnte mein problem aber langsam doch
ist mein keller hier sehr sicher bin ich
schon mal froh dann kann ich mich oben
schlafzimmer daran wagen dann komme ich
voran und dann ab bevor die folge zuerst
müssen wir unbedingt irgendwie stark
gäste machen ja das kann cap doch schon
mal machen wie minecraft bakijews ein
bisschen verändern
in minecraft pakets haus ja aber jetzt
erst mal kartoffeln
ich hab da bin ich durch danach kannst
du denn das fenster bauen das soll ja
nicht groß werden ein paar kisten
reinstellen schreiben hulu
da müssen wir den spanner indien
verlagern denen der krise sinken 1.4 der
werte nicht werden nur sechs ponys macht
es nur für den jeweiligen spieler wenn
ihr eine ahnung wie man den sport
verändert könnt ihr es uns das sagen
stimmt ich schaue heute zum zweifel
läuft endlich einmal ohne budget genau
wenn es ohne ballack geht
bevor wir dafür noch mal paket ihr alles
drauf sie im betrieb da liefert da
lieber
bei mir ist jetzt immer im garten immer
am dienstagabend einen cache ist es
natürlich schön ist auch teilweise toll
teil besser mit knochenbrüchen an das
erwarten wir von euch erde und oder sand
der hammer schlechthin
so sammelte noch sand es ist nacht geben
ich lag schon im bett mit blick so ich
bin ja schon warum gelaufen eine wüste
gesucht und einfach keine gefunden
das kann den am besten machen weil ich
jetzt echt total beschäftigt bin ich bin
froh wenn ich da noch irgendwas
hinkriege ich freue mich schon wieder
ehrlich gesagt auf die nächste
aufnahmestation weil ich aber das dauert
immer so lange ich finde ein haus wie
könnt noch mal so ein bisschen so jetzt
bald schon wieder so weise so jetzt
direkt dann könnten wir vielleicht aber
irgendwann sogar aufkommen dass wir
täglich hochgeladen aber
um 100 ppm software und glauben die
playoffs reicht uns nicht
eben weil ich geh jetz mit in einem rund
führung man nie vergessen wo es sieht so
schön aus
ein kleiner
thomas ich mich selber produzieren sie
selber rumpeln erwartet kann zuerst mal
zu mir kommen würdest du hier klickst du
auf dein handy sowie whatsapp
geschrieben ein zähle ich du gar nicht
ich bin habe ich gefunden im tempel
alter die sind das lassen die guten fans
verteilt man ich dachte ein handy wie
berichtet die ganze zeit wenig zu
spenden
bei mir ist dann heulen das heulen des
auge drauf ist auch ist damit ja auch
darum schön
schlag mich herum führen mit ich habe
auch noch smooth stone ich kann immer so
variieren
sag ich nicht fenster und ein mal wenn
du weißt dass wenn man das noch mal
macht so 14 stone normal verarbeiteten
fenster und an der dritte ist glaube ich
smooth stone ja und ich habe sie alle
du hast du ja ich glaub ich bin formel 1
muss damit auf dem niveau geführt werden
oder ich fühle mich sehr aber ich gucke
mir daraus erst mal mein haus ist so
viel leder du hast ja doch schon die
schilder gemacht die habe ich jetzt hier
gemacht
dafür das hatte ich extra noch neu
gefahren die bilder sind schon wieder
offen mit der wand interagieren die toll
aus aber das hier ist scheiß aus was was
soll der sandstein ja gar nicht sein